yes a very significant update the
confirmation
that the prime suspect in this case who
was arrested
on tuesday evening a serving
metropolitan police officer
has now been charged with kidnapping and
murder that officer
pc wayne cousins an officer attached
to the metropolitan police parliamentary
and diplomatic command those
armed police officers who guard the
sensitive sites including
the houses of parliament and other key
buildings around
london he has been held in custody for
the last few days of course we got the
news yesterday that he'd been taken to
hospital
after suffering a head injury in the
police cell
in which he was housed in wandsworth
police station in south london
taken to hospital treated for that head
injury
and has now been returned to custody
well the decision
was passed to the cps a referral to the
crown prosecution
service and they have confirmed that the
police could go ahead with the charges
in fact i've had
a statement through from rosemary
ainsley the head
of specialist crime at the crown
prosecution service she says
following a referral of evidence by the
metropolitan police
related to the death of sarah everard
the cps
has authorized the police to charge
wayne cousins
with murder and kidnapping he will
appear
the statement goes on to say at
westminster magistrates court
tomorrow the 13th of
march for this first hearing that it
will be
a routine first hearing at a
magistrate's court a great deal of
course
of interest in that court appearance
westminster magistrates court tomorrow
for this police officer pc wayne cousins
now
charged in relation to the kidnap and
alleged murder
of sarah everard in kent